bueno lo primero que podemos decir es
que esto muestra que la visita de nancy
pelosi no era sólo un capricho de ella
sino que tenía que ver con una política
de aquel momento del presidente vaya
intentó despegarse pero estaba yo creo
que consensuado con la representante
legislativa ahora el anuncio de
casablanca pero todavía faltaría que el
congreso norteamericano lo vote no no es
menor eso es una partida de mil 100
millones como usted dijieron para
comprar radares y misiles ni una
invasión inmediata ni un conflicto
armado inmediato sigue que menciona
también que china tiene agudos problemas
por los cuales tiene que mostrarse
activa y sólida internacionalmente a
problemas económicos están mal con la
crisis económica hay cifras de
crecimiento en 1900 aspiradas el
problema del cómic cero acaban de
encerrar una ciudad con 21 millones de
habitantes siendo un futuro congreso del
partido comunista con bastantes
discusiones internas y con impugnaciones
también para el presidente sí y por
último la guerra de ucrania que lo sigue
le sigue dando problemas a nivel
internacional o sea que también está
usando esto como una manera digamos de
distraer algunas otras discusiones de su
población